you're gonna kill it on this one I can
feel it this is gonna be the best one
yes citizens of the reject Nation how's
it going people it's time for another
feature film reaction an animated
feature today we're gonna check out Puss
and Boots The Last Wish and in the
co-host see surprise surprise it's Roxy
stryer a big surprise big surprise he's
supposed to be here today and there and
and yet here we both are wait why
weren't you supposed to be here I wasn't
supposed to be here
how did either of us get here today
either way we're here now I've only seen
the Shrek movies so I am going in very
cold you are an expert no yeah no I have
loved Puss in Boots since last night at
one in the morning killing it yeah big
expert I did just watch the first one it
was really cute okay it was they did a
good job with it I'm curious what the
Last Wish means like what you know
usually I feel like that's not
associated with cats that's gonna be
ambiguous they're not gonna explain it
oh you're on social media right oh yeah
Roxy stryer keeping it simple for the
kids and the World Girls yeah go give
the World Girls some love subscribe hit
notification bells for them for us for
this channel leave a like on this video
and hey guys if you want to see the full
experience with all the stuff that
doesn't make it to the reaction
highlights come on over to patreon.com
real reject sync up with your own copy
of Puss in Boots Last Wish join us for
the adventure Roxy is there any anything
else you want to tell the people before
we get to business you really emphasize
whoa
that's new for you I've not seen this
DreamWorks bumper to put the bad guys in
there
and Dragons
skadoosh that's what Kung Fu Panda says
boss baby trolls what's up Erica my
friend works on trolls oh hi Erica would
you rather be the moon or the boy
um I want to be the boy chilling with
the moon cool you know I gotta think for
moose a little lunar kind of guy you
know I'm a solo girl
that's good balance each other out
you're a world
right first star I see tonight I wish I
may I wish I might have this wish I wish
tonight The Last Wish the titular wish
that was also the best ASMR I've had in
a while yeah Wishing Star fell from the
sky into Super Mario World I'm the
legend of a single wish locked away in
the star waiting
rounded
oh man it's gonna be like the end of
Thor love and thunder everyone's
favorite Thor movie why you think
there's a kid yeah he's gonna wish for
his dead kid to come back
very kid-friendly
hey hola amigo good to see you again oh
he has his boots back hey don't you lose
him kind of this girl like took him for
a sec girl cat she was just puss in bare
feet if it was kind of a sexy move of
hers she was like I've got your boots
[Applause]
yeah sure you can
I should know this but who's voicing
puss it's Santonio Banderas
Tony Flags man you think he's singing
yes I'm gonna say yes for now
I think he's got the pipes that is based
on nothing other than he's a Dreamboat
Bishop's knife trick man all day my
clothes
my wig
hmm
my portrait
[Music]
arrest these filthy patterns and bring
me the head apples and Boots
hey this is a buddy where's the music
clink clink on beat
I wish this is my theme song
[Music]
and his pants come off yes
you wanted that too much classic comedy
people's pants falling down
and he did a p like Zorro
perfect but are his pants coming off or
not
puss in Kaiju
duck tires don't work on cat oh he's a
martini guy I can see it you think it's
Jenner vodka definitely gin
milk and gin oh yeah
that's the kind of white russian I won
well you know that's just like uh your
opinion man and the rest of you play
double time
it's getting a little bossy for me
really yeah I don't love how bossy he is
now like a little too big for his
britches you know maybe that's part of
his Arc
wow
ah it's like a torture method
I like the blend of Animation Styles
they've got going on the subtle mix
I don't know it's making me kind of
dizzy
also that I can see that especially if
you saw this like big and in 3D that's
what the kids like they like a roller
coaster kids love vomiting
[Laughter]
how do you go you think you got his eye
patch
somebody plundered his eye
and sold it for riches whoa you want to
see something cool
get your bell rung
[Music]
[Applause]
my man
I'm like so happy we're done with that
moment really too much it was a lot of
sensory overload
don't worry we're just getting started
one more number I call this one the
legend will never die oh
damn taken out by a bell too you kind of
predicted that get your bell wrong where
am I not to worry you're in good hands
my hands all states hands liters to draw
out the evil humors wow suit yourself
more for me you put a leech down shirt
yeah who knows where it landed died I
have nine lives and how many times have
you died already I haven't counted I am
not really a math guy you know gato
ugh do you think it's gonna be eight
he's died eight times he's already died
nine times he's a zombie now no it's
gonna be eight right It's gotta be eight
It's gotta be one yeah yes it's not your
night
phyllises
I have uh dogs playing poker picture
okay this is a cute Montage I mean
oh this will revolutionize trouble watch
[Laughter]
does this have shellfish in it oh
God he's allergic the oven too high oh
[Music]
that makes eight push I knew it you are
down to your last life I'm very smart
dude you should write movies is there
any safe place you can go any special
someone you can rely on in this moment
of me yeah the girl this is the address
of Mama Luna she is a cat fancier oh
he's on the lookout for a new lap cat oh
no death comes for us all treat
[Music]
takes the whole ball rude don't worry
he's gonna like sprinkle him out to all
the other cats of the land I also like
the Wicked Witch of the West back there
me
that was you that doctor is crazy man
you shouldn't stick to cutting hair all
right what's your prediction on what the
Last Wish is
he's gonna have to give it up for
something he wants to wish for all the
lives but he can't do that
gonna wish for someone to love whoa
can I get your autograph been following
you for a long time
damn cold all right whose voice is this
I know I'm trying to piece together like
it's definitely Ethan Hawke doing a
Spanish accent
he doesn't have a Spanish accent
a little bit
all right let's get it over there
oh you know who it is Poker Face Miss
Congeniality it sounds like him
Benjamin brat oh maybe
yeah
you're not living out to the legend
oh his eyes yeah that's like perspective
bump yeah
whoa
no one mortality
ah
80 cents
I just love the smell of fear hey Palm
in the morning yeah
he's experiencing fear for the first
time
oh no
what's the matter the
for your eye yeah
get up
pick it up
oh buddy is he a wolf yeah in sheep's
clothing
oh now there now there bet who will be
at some point or maybe that's just a
wool coat dude he lost his sword
that would mess the tides up I love a
big beautiful moon like that but that
that's is that how that tides work we'll
watch Cosmos later on
you know what's really weird that they
call him Puss in Boots you're saying it
like it's his best friend Puss and Boots
the boots
yeah no the boots are just as sentient
I am no longer worthy oh he's burying
the boots
now he's just and there was no boots
he's just puss on grass two more a hero
to all a legend words were not enough
no you're doing great it's always great
to give your own eulogy it's a good
exercise what did you think I'd be too
stupid to know what your googly was who
is your favorite Fearless
[Music]
laughs
it's almost weird to see him on all
fours like yeah
meow
you're not from the health department
are you no you're not oh she is so cute
she's like Miss Swizzle yeah hop on the
Magic School Bus
I bet you never even had a name
I shall call you
Nichols bathing with your dirty cat is
disgusting
yeah I I would take a separate shower
after that this is the
SE they must not oh
wow
this is a person party pickle that's
your party
so this is where dignity goes today
um truly bomber pickles I have so many
questions about that bathroom scene just
now because I never thought I would have
to think about because where is his when
he's and then you sure nine so
I hear you
I just don't get why none of them can
speak
because they're domesticated I guess so
they don't have the magic oh no
my dude
that's a Rip Van Winkle beard really let
himself go
these are too small but these ones
these ones are just right
oh my God yes
that's fun
track that cat see that's who you should
be totally just get yourself three big
old Burly dudes to follow you around
do you mind I'm trying to eat here I
mean now whatever what's wrong with that
sorry it's a dog
you're a talking cat you're a talking
cat let's talk
talking cat like the film a talking cat
it definitely is a dog right
it's funny despite all this best friend
bonding you're still a mystery to me
pickles what's your story my story
do you feel like they're socks or
mittens they're mins
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go definitive
Mitten
what's happening I need the practice I'm
gonna be a therapy dog someday when
people feel bad they can rub my belly
it'll make him feel better this is so
good
I don't want to touch your belly okay so
what do you want I won't
to be left alone
this is a lovely home I was just
thinking I would literally do anything
to live there
you're back oh I never left
who are you more similar to uh
definitely the dog that would definitely
be more of the dog
I never left he found me
I just got a Jackie outfit on
for the legendary pushing boots have you
perhaps seen him too soft is that
Windstone Jason Statham we'll see we'll
take bets
I don't think we've got anything right
so far nope sniff him out you don't tell
me what to do do what she says fine but
all I can smell is cat pee oh yeah it
probably smells disgusting in there oh
sure
probably be a slightly lightheaded
leaving a place like this
oh
here we go
[Music]
no way that skirt is staying up like
that it's uh it's a modesty skirt it's
rigid it's good everyone loves
for this one is a ginger you think this
scruffy geriatric bag of bones looks
like a legend
dead and buried dead well that's that
then what say we going hibernate
we have one chance to steal it without
it we'll never find the wishing
stuff
that star has one wish to Grant One Wish
think of what that could mean for us you
think his one wish is for more lives but
then he has to use it on something else
that's what I'm going with yeah
but if this person boots is such a big
deal maybe we shouldn't be desecrating
his grave no I don't think he will mine
was he
is me
too I'm so addicted the movie and this
haul has my initials on it
endlessly impressed I am why what does
it stand for in this stands for John
Hall
yes duh get in and get out easy busy let
me squeezy I brought you a sword not a
sword it's a stick it's a stick sword go
home I love him again not friends rap
for luck
let's start using that he's on
his eyes he is finally to see ourselves
that is that's definitely a Greg is
definitely Puss in Boots
Greg and Boots representation matters
yeah
[Music]
oh I hated that oh I hate this delicious
oh JH Jack Horner Jack Hall
yeah
you couldn't let me have that no is it
the map to the Wishing Star
we must get this to the trophy oh my God
I hate this guy that's John Mulaney I'm
pretty sure he gives me the
heebie-jeebies bro yeah that character
design is disturbing it's truly
disturbing after so many years of
searching this is my moment
with the thumb
forever stained the master of all magic
hey little Jack could you do the thumb
thing like in the fairy tale wasn't a
fairy tale it was only a nursery rhyme
oh
oh is this real yeah pulled out a plum
and said what a good boy am I jack horn
is real I think it's a real like nursery
rhyme I've never heard that
oh my God because you've probably heard
Pinocchio way more
lover cat
yeah I've heard so much about this lover
cat she had no claws
[Music]
Katie pools kitty
kitty Soft Paws okay maybe she got her
own boots that's what happened you
promised us our weight in gold ever hear
of the Midas touch oh cool dibs
our weight in gold I hate it it's
disgusting well I love it it's
distinguished Salma Hayek or Penelope
it's not a good look that we can't tell
the difference you should know you're
the Puss in Boots movies expert
you watch this less than 24 hours ago
good girl you robbed me you set me up
you said you were going on some
spiritual Retreat Namaste and you're
supposed to be dead I got better
crank I can't tell she We Like Her
I'm enjoying her no I mean like
is she bad guy or good guy Goldie yeah
[Music]
mediocre
you know chaotic neutral maybe the best
Thief has won
[Music]
her mask is sick yeah I want one
oh I don't know why we do all the slow
motion with the animation you know to
make it feel more real oh is that a
snake what are you gonna do with it
[Music]
pies puss in pies
this idiot
oh no don't die
hey look I found a sandwich in here I
think it's tuna
I don't think that it's tuna actually
also he's allergic to maybe just
shellfish at least yeah who is this guy
I'm pussy's best friend no he isn't it
and his therapy dog definitely not
trust me trust you like I did in Santa
Coloma really Santa Coloma
oh is that for the first movie I don't
remember if that's the name of where it
was but
I realized that she didn't take his
boots she just got her own so he always
had his boots
[Music]
oh that'll do it accept
s
my man oh he's getting cocky again
cool it's Goldilocks and the Bears is
the wolf the villain in that no I used
to get a Little Red Riding they were
right here yeah now porridge is the real
villain too hot too cold yeah the
commodification of porridge forcing this
poor girl to either we're gonna see
Little Red Riding Hood then hey Alice in
Wonderland it's an Easter regulatorium
in here
hey
[Music]
get you my kitties and your little dog
and it was a pumpkin Carriage we got
some Cinderella going on yeah the Dark
Forest
far within its bounds you'll find the
Stars
plastic is it bad that I want them to
kiss not at all
cat kiss I got a kiss cut the tension
what's your name oh I've been called all
kinds of things dog bad dog stupid dog
big rats small Pig rat face butt nugget
for brains you know whoa they're going
for it that was interesting edgy but I
liked butt nugget butt nugget yeah yeah
yeah I've used button nugget before no
one's that dumb no one's that nice I
don't trust you me neither do I trust
him more than I trust you no
[Music]
yeah
the chase is on
I really can't stand him
this is who I want to be someday Jack
Horner yeah
this does the initial thing you want to
be bulbous I want my legs to be
incapable of supporting my frame but
still doing it somehow I got the
sandwich this must be the Dark Forest
freaky cool design yeah I love it it's
that icicles
it's back ready one two after you wait
what so mean foreign
I can't stand you sometimes bro like you
wouldn't do the same I would never
all right
[Music]
whoa
really I'm like softballs
yeah you are may I please see them up no
seriously you won't let me hold it for
even one minute nope you've got to trust
me oh what's going on with his eyes oh
figure oh
oh really you call that cute
oh no oh look at her oh the lashes wait
a second so oh my God what the pause the
office
kiss kiss kiss kiss
follow these Enchanted chart it knows
your path and knows your heart
they all have good hearts
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
oh
okay bummer odor
over Undertaker reach through the cave
of lost souls really let me take a look
[Music]
oh everyone's path is different but I
don't want them to separate me neither
sometimes in life you don't always get
what you want but if you try sometimes
Rose mountains of Misery the abyss of
Eternal loneliness no sheeps not
loneliness I don't even have a wish but
can I try it it's gonna be the easiest
bath yeah
the Rainbow Bridge
we get through the pocket full of posies
what then drift down the river of
relaxation that sounds fun no fair why
does he get the good ones wonder the
feels of quick and easy solutions
this is your quest I don't want to
impose you hold them up really well
don't you cross me or your name will be
ferromuerto okey dokey that's a bar dead
dog that's less of a bar
what's your one wish
um
give me a minute
it's one wish for for the rest of your
time you gotta make a good wish can't
tell you birthday wish rules or whatever
I've had your wishes something stupid
[Music]
this must be the pocket full of posies
ashes ashes We All Fall Down it's
running time
[Music]
are these actually called Posies
they're hydroposes oh thank you
that's a good question though I don't
know if I've actually ever seen a real
Posey I think all you have to do is stop
and smell the roses
all I smell is bullsh
a lot of this is an edgy family film
well it is Puss in Boots it's true that
is it is true
yeah me and my litter mates live with
the family a family full of pranksters
who like to play hide and seek and I was
always it they tried putting me in a
packing crate a dumpster
and they put me in a sock with a rock in
it and then throw me in a river I nod a
hole in the sock and I swapped to the
surface
damn
gave you the mafia treatment you of all
people should have a wish I already have
a comfy sweater and two best friends I
got everything I could wish for he's so
cute he's gonna teach them both a little
something
oh lovely this is so cute oh I'm so in
right now stop and enjoy life for a
minute did you come up with your wish I
can't tell you it's not gonna come true
I'll come up with I'll come up with one
my wish is to know what my wish would be
my wish is to be more decisive
dang this looks sick this is trippy
start chopping on it stop and smell the
roses the heck out of this bike
whoa
whoa oh my God that was sick
hey there all right magical Locust
defoliate no it's so mean no Jurassic
world to me what are you there a deadly
fairy Put a Spell on the forest then I I
judge I sit on your shoulders
Jimmy Stewart
but also yes I keep my secrets and I
play my cards close that's how you get a
Winnie hat never trust anyone they took
her his
sweater it's like a sock sweater
you were right the beer is disgusting oh
I won't make your bag wow
there's that handsome face I remember
the face I haven't seen since I Santa
Coloma no so that must be oh that's his
hometown I think that she met him in
this is a path to get my wish you mean
my wish you mean My Wish
sorry
make with the map or we'll see what the
unicorn horn really does you're not
gonna shoot a puppy are you a jack yeah
in the face why oh my gosh
a lot of this looks like a video game
it's got a little bit of video game a
little bit of that spider versus
jitteriness yeah a little bit of stuff
that kind of looks hand-drawn
the wolf
yeah oh
no go get the map
thanks for the maps of pose
nostalgic Pines it's like pining for
Nostalgia clever
[Music]
oh
what's wrong
been there honey oh oh my God he's a
therapy dog he is
oh that's really sweet thank you thank
you burrito
perrito you left her at the altar he was
wrong I know I am ashamed
to her so badly yeah oh there's the wish
don't hurt the people you love kitty I
love the map we'll get it back we've
been in worse pickles who told you the
name
foreign
this isn't real none of this is
is great
[Music]
too soft
just right
[Music]
do you know that was gonna happen I'm a
Futures here the day A Little Orphan
girl broke into our cabin and stole our
hearts oh
came just right see I want her to win
too yeah I told you I liked her
I think Mama bears Olivia Coleman
oh you okay
see I am good so good
soft pass Saves the Day the first time I
ever felt the fear I ran it was a
mistake it's okay no it's not okay don't
tell him it's okay it's not okay
wait what well I knew I could never
compete with you one true love
yourself
John
shut the front door yeah I didn't see
that coming I think she did show up
I think you might be right I think
that's a good call she's let him off the
hook but she showed up she's giving him
a chance yeah rebuild you know I never
had much as a kid just loving parents
stability in a mansion and a thriving
baked goods Enterprise for me to inherit
useless crap sounds good
[Applause]
can't bake a pie without losing a dozen
men oh
your wish is horrible you're horrible
yeah yep what took you so long idiot oh
his wings chatty are you
okay you take the window I'll take the
chimney what do I take it looks like a
Thomas Kinkade painting uh the guard
area yeah yeah on your six got your
rears eyeballed and covered hands and
crew staring at your butts dogs are good
at that if you play your cards right
maybe we could share the wish
oh
yeah stuck in the honey
nowhere to go softballs let's see what
the map has to say
this is a cool premise with like it
keeps changing depending on who's
holding it yeah getting good there
we're coming down
[Music]
I like that both of their boots have
heels yeah major eels
hey
[Music]
oh this is so beautiful
I'll find a way out of here yeah listen
to him trust you go get burrito pussy's
gonna be fine because it's always been
fine especially now that he has no more
lives to burn he's gonna be a proper
party now about all nine of us are here
one who is your favorite Fearless hero I
do remember this one yeah it's a banger
speaking from one orphan to Another
goldie you won the orphan lottery I like
his jib as well let's keep him what
he crimed
[Music]
shut the piece who plays the shark in
Finding Nemo oh that sounds like
goodness
don't do it don't go back to your old
ways puss were you really happy back
then no Nostalgia is the number one
cause of depression well he doesn't even
have a soul
Savage Man Savage burn without us
[Music]
it's intoxicated is he real right now
okay I was there to witness all of them
[Music]
boots laughs in the face of death oh is
he actually deaf yeah seems like that oh
undeath straight up and I've come for
years
straight up whose voice is this I can
see their face too like it's driving me
nuts go ahead run firing makes it more
fun for me come on soft pause you gotta
rescue my man's heart
do not leave her no no no no no no no no
no
[Music]
horse All Is Lost what is this the star
the star
you think it's a solid liquid or gas it
is crystalline
solid solid
transition what's your just right what's
out blasted important I'm getting a
family that's what a problem probably
then everything will be will be just
right
if this is something that will make you
happy we'll get you that wish
oh
but I was in on Goldie
and now a hater no it's just me dies
terribly by the way the oh now that you
care about my wish because you haven't
asked me but the only wish to wish for
is to wish for more wishes sorry I can't
help but
I'm stealing your wish I am on my last
life I need to get my lives back without
them I am not what the legend get your
lives back
just keep them out of mind the dog
perito should obviously get the wish
yeah
you know how I'm feeling dizzy yeah you
know like those locked off POV
panning shots I need your help duly
noted but a little
bit whoa
A lot of people get exploded in this
movie yeah out of death
[Music]
Goldie don't be a big brat
like I told you baby you're the smash
I'm the crap yes
I mean literally anybody but you no this
is good this is gonna be good I'm glad
for him he deserves it maybe it's time
to bury the hatchet
I
I've only ever had one life sharing it
with you and Kitty has made it pretty
special one life is enough is enough
who's that he's here for me
[Music]
who's getting the Last Wish I need your
prediction yeah
[Music]
it's interesting they can all see death
yeah maybe it's the magic of the star
ah the little dagger say hello to my
cartito blade thank you
[Music]
Ito makes everything so cute I know
oh dang dude beast mode pick it up pick
it up pick it up menacing
he goes away right he's gonna leave
look death in the face and just and make
the big old cute eyes I come here for an
arrogant little Legend who thought he
was Immortal but I don't see him anymore
oh with his eight other lives the wish
is yours
you deserve someone you can trust come
on no no give it to the dog
coming out of the bag
magic sneeze oh
no no
no
thank you
[Music]
The Last Wish Starlight Star Bright
first star I see tonight I wish I may
burrito I wish I might please don't make
that wish
oh seriously are you having a hernia or
something
do it do it buddy
there's such pools of vulnerability
don't you know I'm dead inside by the
way your nose is bleeding I was just
buying some time for a team friendship
uh let's go
get him Goldie
oh torture
hey
no wish no one gets a wish
what did I do to deserve this everything
every
[Laughter]
Terminator
I wish somebody made a wish
this is dope I wish somebody may wish
that's your wish it's full circle one
knife spend with you is all that I could
wish for please make out cats cat cat
love let's do it even it's so lame
they're just gonna hold the hands
romance isn't appropriate for children
all right between habits of violence and
that's it sorry you didn't get your wish
gold enough but I did Mama everything is
just right oh no you've made me cry
I love love this little b story yeah you
know if it's
if it's about just
they kind of like it since that's what
my friends call me
you know to be honest jumper is pretty
good yeah but no
Workshop in it
yeah
yes there literally was no Last Wish
[Music]
team friendship
team friendship we did not agree to this
yeah it makes us look ridiculous too
late now it's official
oh
Steady As She Goes burrito
I thought that was gonna be the kiss and
to see some old friends oh Shrek
you think don't care you think they're
Fiona I don't think no no no no like
some of the side characters Maybe
we're gonna go see the gingerbread man
again
he turned into a gold egg
see see so solid but didn't you think
like there could be one wish
I think that's part of the message is
that you know in this life you're not
gonna get a magic wish and thus it
behooves you to look around past the
hardships and the trials to the things
that are already here to bless your
experience sounds like somebody who's
definitely not getting a magic wish hey
you know okay Antonio vendors Salma
Hayek okay
Harvey yet is he on what we do in the
shadows oh I should have called him out
Florence peace
there you go
got it got it
Ray Winstone that was a good one really
good job okay good good different guy I
have no idea who that is for a second
yeah for a second I thought baby was
Wagner Mora he was in did you see
Elysium he's on like narcos yeah okay
probably why the voices sounded so good
is they got some really good voice
people yeah yeah no for sure
and it's hard because you know it's I
feel like with every animated movie
people get have different levels of
supporter frustration for having like
you know major actors do the voice yeah
where was Chris Pratt in this where was
Chris Pratt it's not complete without
Chris Pratt we have one wish is to have
Chris Pratt voiced at least half of
these guys yeah is to have Chris Pratt
not voice anybody
you don't want to hear Rocket Raccoon
Mario I do how'd you know I'm excited
yeah me too actually I'm excited stop
specifically despite despite Chris Brown
but uh but yeah Florence Pew yeah one
and two because like you're so I am so
used to seeing Florence do an American
accent that I always forget she's
British so this is like the first time I
think I've probably heard her actual
voice throughout a movie see that's the
closest to a kiss we're gonna get oh I
can't believe they didn't make out
yeah I wanted to see some like Kitty
tongue on tongue like
yeah with those like really extreme
angles and stuff
oh yeah and the close-up on the cute
eyes and see like the little like you
know the little claw things on their
tongues like you know connecting and and
velcroing together claw thanks yeah cats
have like coarse tongues is there gonna
be a third one
I don't know I mean it certainly feels
like it watching this at least
I come
uh yeah I mean
oh
oh see this is this is one of the few
kinds of movies where it's like if they
had a sing-along or some kind of thing
where you could dance in the theater
let's do it maybe there'll be more songs
in the next one though I kind of feel
like the whole thing should be a Musical
full-on musical I would be down for that
I would be down
[Music]
I can't believe how many lines I
predicted in this movie dude
I am a child
so hence exactly you speak the language
sick Bro
I would watch your animated children's
movie family I should say this is a
family and this this movie seemed like
it it wanted to push every boundary of
what PG can offer you didn't want to
push the boundaries or push the boundary
they wanted to push the boundaries and
they did push them they heard it here so
many words
like in that one sequence it's like so
many times that you're like okay I get
the joke but the first time they did it
you're like that's a real bleeped out
swear word there totally like a cunning
child could piece together what he just
said what did you think
I thought this was lovely and I've been
here like again I do not have the most
comprehensive uh viewing history of the
shrekiverse
you know though Shrek is love life and
all of the above I was really dazzled
and delighted by this because you know
it's that movie that came out where I
was like okay another Puss in Boots
Shrek movie it'll probably be a whatever
and then you know it's gotten these
nominations and I keep hearing people
say how great it is and sure enough this
is like things like this are gratifying
to me where I'm like oh this is
fun enough but also way more than that
yeah yeah and like I thought they had a
lot of really beautiful visual Artistry
I thought the story was solid and not
like all right we gotta find something
else for Puss and Boots to do because
this is a popular franchise like it made
sense yeah it made sense I thought it
did nice things for the characters like
you said I really liked the gold like
the Goldilocks B plot grew into
something that I just wasn't expecting
that was really nice to have kind of
running alongside all this and to
further illustrate the point they could
have easily made her a villain and that
whole storyline another villainous
storyline but it's like everybody is the
hero of their own Journey obviously she
was the hero of hers and that was cool I
think that this is it was better than
the first person boots but doesn't hold
a candle to Shrek I mean Shrek is Shrek
a Shrek Shrek is Shrek and it was such
like a groundbreaker at the time because
I feel like it was really on the
avant-garde of like
we're bringing a more Snappy a more
adult accessible sensibility to a family
thing and we're also being meta and
crossing over all these fairy tales and
stuff and so yeah it's like the just the
like
sheer fret like Shrek seems to have as
much as a meme now like it feels like
it's influenced a lot in terms of just
the scope of at least animated movies in
America since it's come out yeah totally
and also um him and Fiona make out so
they do they do that's what apparently
that matters so what you're saying is
the trick is vastly better just simply
due to the makeout quotient it is yeah
that is what I said so okay I I don't
know if it was with Tom
but at least again
I wasn't there okay the problem is even
if it wasn't in the actual movie cut
someone has animated where it very much
was and you can find that out there if
you
said you're already 10 steps ahead of me
I don't know I mean yeah this this I
think excels just by being
a good story told well you know which is
sort of Timeless you've been doing a lot
of animated stuff you think this holds
up to or right now in 2023 the animated
genre this is pretty much as good as it
gets
I
I mean there are certainly things that
you could do that are much more out
there and and you know
yeah more off the beaten path with like
story beats and stuff but as as far as
like the Assembly of an animated movie
today goes I would say yeah because this
manages to incorporate and blend a lot
of the visual Aesthetics that have been
sort of at the Forefront of Animation
lately again like there's a little bit
of
spider-verseiness in the way that they
incorporate like the um
I forget what they call this like the
action lines where it's like somebody
jumps at the camera and they've got like
little action lines or things that look
like the frame rate has been slowed down
on like a character like the way they
really mix
I feel like there's a uniformity that
you get used to when you look at like a
Disney Animation or a Pixar movie where
it's all this kind of one
thing happens yes one palette of
Animation whereas here again there were
textures that looked very they were
playing and yeah yeah so it gave it this
like additional sense of handcraftedness
even though it is like all in a computer
so totally a couple times you kind of
related it to spider verse which I feel
like was
uh you doing the most but I hear what
you're saying I mean spider versus like
I am still here thanks for asking post
Oh I thought it was going to be a whole
thing
but yeah I mean spider verse for that
yeah like hyper kinetic like we're
borrowing from comic books and we're
making it yeah look a little bit more
multimedia than just one kind of
Animation style you're supposed to look
past
um so yeah like
this will be now a new Touchstone I can
use in the future when talking about
these things because yeah spider-verse
is like cranked up to 15 on that on that
it's not quite 50 you said 15 that's
awkward
I like spider-verse better than you do I
guess I guess so or at least you find it
more overwhelming than I do
but uh what did you think of it I think
it was it was really solid definitely
definitely preferred this one to the
first one just because there were more
layers and more characters I cared about
there was the big twist of the first one
being that Humpty Dumpty is tricking him
and isn't actually his homie and then we
twist back and he untrix them and and
works with him so I thought that that
was a very simple uh as opposed to this
with like the death element the goldie
element the jam with his thumb element
you know it was just more kind of going
on which I appreciated yeah and also I
really like Soft Paws and I loved she's
in the first one too but I loved
watching their dynamic in this one they
kind of seemed like a match made in
heaven and then perito isn't in the
first one so perlito elevates this for
sure oh yeah absolutely I'm big into
Patty
[Music]
I should have called him out too it's
like it sounds like not you yeah you
didn't I did I no I will I will die on
this hill I was like I can't tell for
sure because I only have what we do in
the shadows to go off of but I was like
that sounds so much like Guillermo I
feel as of right now you're lying to me
I would never have got Wagner Mora
because I kept sitting there going I
know it's not Javier Bardem but he's got
kind of that like Oaken quality of like
Javier Bardem sometimes when he speaks
it sounds like like a like a ritual tree
or something like that and and uh and I
never would have got him okay but I will
die on the perito hill
of his of his voice act perito wouldn't
let you die on that Hill that's true
that's true he would have me pet his
belly and he would do the eyes thing
he'd use his one wish to save you I know
instead of tearing the wish apart you
could have wished for solving world
hunger if you were gonna just tear it
apart you know you don't have to wish
for yourself you could have wished for
her a better life for everyone yeah
anything but instead they were like nah
we all got what we wanted nobody needs
this wish that's true they were all
selfish at the end honestly they're all
the worst they suck and uh this is a bad
movie now
sorry I just did that to you it didn't
last long it's okay no this is how I can
do it for five seconds this is this is a
good life lesson you know this is what
happens you're welcome reality comes
crashing in and you have to temper uh
you know your sentimentality yeah I'm
glad that you know we and the children
who are watching this yeah that was for
kids of the real rejects uh you know we
are all learning this today and growing
for the little ones at home what I'm
saying is if you like this movie you are
selfish uh Angry you need to go to
therapy little child yes yeah yeah you
should uh go out and do some community
service and really think about what you
did here today think about what you've
done today
but yeah hopping back into because the
other thing that was kind of fun is I
know this comes out of Shrek I've met
Puss and Boots through Shrek but it's
been a minute since I've seen any of the
Shrek movies and so coming back here I
was like oh cool like the the
convergence of fairy tale characters and
worlds still exists here and it's not
necessarily like as in your face or as
much of the point but it's still like it
makes this feel like it's all part of a
big world without feeling obnoxiously
like ah Cinematic Universe you know that
was a really fun element of it like even
what's in the bag and the references but
with the cart and the Pumpkin and all
the chimney of it all that was really
cool I like that too anything that makes
it feel like you're kind of a kid again
and you're dealing with all the fairy
tales yeah the lines and stuff and with
you there yeah because it works anyway
but if you get what the references are
it works that much better you know
what's your favorite character my
favorite character
I don't I feel like it's a it's
underwhelming to say it's either like
Puss and soft positives are so great
they're both gonna say puss like soft
pause is is so lovely and I just love
them together but puss is like he's
great I just love watching him I love
Antonio banderas's voice I love all the
different iterations of his exploits and
whatnot like he is a very I get why this
character has spun off and why people
care if you love put so much then why
don't you wear his boots I will now and
I'm gonna go back and re-watch and watch
for the first time in the first movie
and be like you know what this is my
franchise now I think you're gonna like
the first one I don't think you're gonna
like it as much as you like this one I
don't anticipate that either but you
know I can imagine at least going in and
be like oh yeah you know it's pretty fun
you're one of my favorite character what
is your favorite what's your guess uh
Goldie
because that could be you I did really
like Goldie no but mine's the other
lackluster answer soft pause okay I just
love her like she's great she's hard
around the edges but she also when we
see her start to try to teach perrito
and like listen to perito I'm like you
are the perfect balance of tough
exterior but like at the end of the day
you were gonna wish for somebody to
trust yeah it's just so relatable and I
know but I do think we should have seen
this I really feel like she didn't
actually show up to the wedding I know
that she did show up to the wedding and
she's claiming she didn't yeah that
would have been it would have been cool
to
almost like have an interlude or
something or yes see it from at least
see from her perspective what that day
looked like to and I went down a whole
journey and we never went down that
Journey like I was like oh and then what
happened was and then she was there and
then he wasn't there and then the the
movie was just like no no he just said
what it was stop stop going down that
path you've made things up rocks that
feels like something that they probably
wanted to do and maybe had to trim for
time yeah possibly possibly or even if
it wasn't what I'm predicting any
version of just seeing the wedding and
whatever it is they probably cut the
whole thing yeah because this is already
what like an hour and 42 minutes and
that's you know that's that's asking
some again like I
from talking to animators over time I
know it kind of drives them nuts that
animation gets sort of in America
pigeonholed into being the thing for
kids when it's like a whole medium unto
itself yeah
um but you know I feel like being that
they definitely want children in the
theater for a movie like this an hour
and once you're over an hour and 40
you're kind of like okay we're asking a
lot of the attention it did feel a
little long the second act dragged a bit
here and that's okay for me and you but
I do think that the first one was 90
minutes and this one did feel like about
10 minutes longer you know you can feel
yourself being like okay let's get to
that wish What's Happening Here who's
gonna end up at the at the star yeah you
start to be like think about okay let's
get there and then once we get there
that third act goes really really fast
yeah yeah and I mean like I thought they
they did nicely to at least
even though yeah like it is it is on the
longer side I think they at least
managed to
there was never anything where I was
like we'll just get rid of this yeah
like there was a lot of interesting idea
like I loved the idea of the Dark Forest
and that it changes depending on who's
going through and then it kind of looks
back into you as you're pursuing what
you think you want out of it what would
your dark force if you're holding the
map what do you think it would have been
oh man oh God uh it would have been like
walk down the the bridge of
Bridge of wistfulness and then uh uh I
love the bridge of wistfulness yeah sure
sure so yours would have been celebrated
though
no I mean perrito's like got the ideal
like everything's fine in your Zen so
you know you're gonna have an easy time
in here as long as you remember to look
around whereas me I feel like
there would be like the valley of
anxieties you know yeah the uh the the
swamp of
self-doubt I don't know why I just
thought you're gonna say sweat the swamp
a sweat I'm a sweaty guy it's a swamp of
sweat swamp swamp puss in sweat swamp
listen sweats that's who he's gonna go
become now he's gonna be chilling after
the pandemic he's now pushing swallows
and sweats he puts his boots on when he
has to go check the mail or whatever but
that's about it listen do I have to put
my boots on today yeah that's part three
and he's dealing with geriatric issues
but that but that too like I like that
they're dealing with mortality and he's
aging and it's like clever and fun
because the nine lives thing but also
like you know that's a coming to grips
with the fact that you don't have
forever and you can't just always be
this you know you can't be the character
you create for everybody else to see you
know I think it's kind of a nice and a
bit sophisticated of an idea to go for I
think you've automatically I think the
default you associate with animated fair
is like believe in yourself you know
that's totally and it'll be that um
which there is some of that but yeah
like I like the way that they had death
in here like actually personified Yes
actually confront death yeah and the way
they realize that like there's a lot of
stuff that isn't like you know too much
but is like kind of intense and very
visually striking for a movie like this
like when he has those encounters with
death with the red eyes and then
everything gets tinted red and you know
you really feel the impact impact of
these blades and then the sights and
everything and like yeah there's it's
really uh I mean part of this is a
horror movie you know that's exactly
what I'm picking up you're putting down
it's definitely a horror movie the Death
part really did work for me too actually
though because I do feel like the whole
time sometimes I watch movies selfishly
and you're thinking about yourself
during it right and I kind of was
feeling annoyed with puss at times
because I'm like bro I'm so sorry that
you only get nine lives and you're on
your last one and you've already used up
eight of them like I would die to have
nine lives you know I would live so
differently it's the whole time I'm
thinking but we only have one life I
only have one life he only gets one life
it's so annoying that you're mad about
this and then they addressed that yeah
and I was like oh okay I'm glad that
they're realizing like when perlito
talks about it and then he's like I
don't I only have one life but I'm so
happy because I'm with my friends and I
was like that's it perito tell them be
here now perito yeah and then he kind of
gets there where he's just like I only
have one life but I'm gonna fight for it
screw you death and I'm like yeah that's
the point the point isn't that you had
nine it's the point is that this is now
you get ones like the rest of us so go
work really hard to live your life yeah
don't don't don't spend all your time
looking back on a The Glory Days but be
like oh if I had only had this mindset
then you know like just be here now and
make the most out of it Namaste Namaste
all right any stray thoughts anything do
we miss anything straight thoughts like
stray cats gray cat strut are you doing
that on purpose oh no
that's my my jazzier Bill and Ted
kind of um
sounded more like rocket power
yeah yeah
yeah squid we got this
it's good
well guys this was super delightful
great voice cast great animation good
writing you know
everybody everyone who was involved and
even some people who weren't involved we
guessed them too above and beyond
definitely we covered all the base
well guys if you enjoyed this video let
us know leave a comment leave a like
check out the World Girls check out Roxy
stryer everywhere social media books are
sold and hey before we leave this place
Let's uh let's make a wish for a lucky
patch
Andrew Hayes buddy I wanted to shout you
out today because you know honestly this
is an embarrassment of riches I'm not
sure how many Andrew Hayes could be so
many characters from this movie and
right now I'm torn because you know he's
kind of a short guy you know he's kind
of a compact dude but he's also uh you
know he's he's got spunk you know he's
got uh uh imagination he's good picking
locks and stuff he he works for a
security company you think he's puss
he's either puss or he's perito because
the other thing is whenever we talk to
Andrew he's just got this good natured
way of delivering things and uh I just
always feel better when I talk to him I
don't know I don't know oh so that's the
perrito part he's a combo it's like I
would rub your belly Andrew and and feel
at ease and feel kind of like things are
gonna be okay good Andrea take that with
you he'll rub your belly and he means
that truly and you don't even have to do
the cute eyes like if you want to you
can but can you try
for Andrew
this is really good
it's really
really good I don't know what's
happening with the hands but Andrew
appreciates it
that's for you Andrew it's for you
Andrew oh we love you here at the real
Rejects and uh stay pledged buddy we'll
catch you next time
in Boots
[Music]
killing it
was that a really good cat sound or no
it was a great cat sound that sounded
yeah is that really good yeah it sounds
like copper because like he'll be out
there everyone's got a different meow
and he'll be out there half the time
while we're shooting just oh wait that
was actually a bomb what's wrong you let
me
throughout the day it's just burned into
my subconscious
a magic subconscious
[Music]